I have a terrible experience,
made a lot of mistakes when I was young
and child.
I think if you succeed,
every mistakes become a legendary.
If you feel that's just the garbage,
you know what I'm saying?
I think
everybody has great stories.
Everybody had a lot of mistakes,
everybody have lot of problems.
But very few people listen to you one
day where it becomes successful.
People listened to you say,
wow,
you are great.
I'm not that great.
I was born a normal family
and I'm not a good as schooling.
Of course,
I tried to study hard,
but as a boy,
you know,
my school was not that good at that
time.
So I felt looking for jobs,
looking for joining university,
joining good schools.
But I never give up.
And I think there's one thing I learned
is that,
um,
why,
why you should have a chance to be
successful.
Everybody should get used to beat,
get used to feel and get used to be
accepted by other people.
Why other people should help you.
You should earn the right to be helped.
So the thing I learned is that don't
give up.
My opportunity has not come yet.
When everybody complain,
that is the opportunity.
I always thought when I was young,
when I was graduate in the high school
or university,
I thought Bill Gates took up my job.
You know,
Bill Gates did all the successful
things.
Larry Ellison from Oracle,
they,
they took all the wonderful
opportunities.
IBM benefit,
we people have no opportunity
and I think our aim too high.
I should aim to support and help the
people around me to tiny things.
I never thought I could be today after
18 years,
Ali Baba become today's size.
Not because I'm smart.
I don't think I'm a smart person,
but I have.
I work with a lot of smarter people
and most of the smart people,
they always want to do successful
things,
quick,
easy things.
And I think it's not easy to be
successful quickly.
Every time.
Everything we do,
we prepare for 10 years.
I know I'm not smart.
If we want to be successful,
we have to win 10 years later.
we have to work with smart people.
If we want to be successful,
we should make a lot of mistakes and
never give up.
A lot of people,
they make mistake them problem.
They give up.
We never give up.
We learn from the stakes
and I think when we're filled their
message,
the experience that I want to give you a
device,
I want to give you,
you a judge.
When this person will be successful,
not by where his cell,
he thinks it's his fault or the other
Ford,
if he thinks my field,
because of the others,
this guy has no chance.
Those people who feel always think,
hmm,
it is my fun.
I did not do the properly.
I should change care or change you
there.
These guys have opportunities,
so I learned a lot from those people who
fail.
I learned a lot from those people who
made mistakes.
I learned a lot from my mistakes.
So this is what I,
when I,
this is my life attitude.
When I feel I say,
see,
I will fail when I succeed.
I said,
well,
I never know.
I could be successful.
This make me very positive and
optimistic and because of so many
mistakes,
too much of failure that make me never
complained.
God,
I get used to that.
We are making this stick everyday.
Even to today,
we made stupid decisions almost every
day.
Nobody knows.
We thought as smart,
but finding approves stupid.
But we learn.
We'll do again.
We'll learn.
That's the way.
That's the live attitude.
Thank you.
I'll leave a,
bob was born in China,
but it was created for the whole world.
So can you tell us what Alibaba does now
outside of China and in particular in
Russia?
We're good buddy.
Alibaba builds notice of the lawsuit,
the [inaudible] Moses
chimps than you might sally.
Bubba [inaudible].
Yeah.
Ali Baba stuff from no money,
no technology,
no people in my apartment,
18 people decide that we want the using
Internet technologies to help small
business.
That was the idea.
After 18 years,
we grow from 18 people.
Two today close to 60,000 people.
It is really not easy,
but we survive today.
We are one of the biggest internet
companies in the world.
I think we're lucky
we made so many mistakes,
but we still survive.
How can you be continued to be lucky?
That is the question.
Keep on asking me.
I think if you want to continue to be
lucky,
you have to give your lot to the others.
You give luck to the others.
You help others.
The operas in the future,
we're helping you.
That was my,
our thinking in the past 10 years.
Ali Baba was born in China,
but Alibaba should not be a Chinese
company.
The name the day when I choose the name
Ali Baba,
Ali Baba is not a Chinese name.
It's a Arabic name and Iran's that is
Iran nicknamed Turkey says taking him.
I don't,
I don't know we're in name,
but it's the name from Alibaba,
1000 when mistakes or Alibaba,
one founder,
one nights the story.
We want to make this company a company
that Boeing Chinar enabled the world
helping the global young company,
young people.
As I said that every century there's a
company for the century.
Microsoft was the company of last
century as a great century.
Ivn was a company of the century.
What is the company of this century,
21st century and I think it's,
we should not think about Alibaba.
We should always,
we make money,
serve Chinese.
We should have made the money,
serve the world,
serve this century.
This only think in that way we can do
more.
Our company today is big but compared to
yesterday it was big but compared to
tomorrow it is still a tiny company.
The world changes so fast.
So this is our thinking.
We want to make all the Moba be the
company of the century.
We want make Alibaba the company
supporting global,
small,
medium size companies.
We want to make this company supporting
global young people and we want to make
this company to making sure women can
have a more jobs online because people
don't care.
You're a woman or man online.
This is what we want to do and we're
doing a lot outside China,
Southeast Asia.
We are also doing lot in Indian.
We just started doing more in America
and the and also Canada.
In Russia we have a small business
that's called Ali Express.
Maybe I'll express here is very big,
but in Cha,
all company,
probably less than 1% of our business,
Ali Express,
but on express is not our main purpose
of doing business in Russia.
We do not want to be a Russia e commerce
company.
Okay.
We are not ecommerce company.
We help other company become ecommerce.
We hope what we want to do in Russia,
we wanted to help you rusher to boot up
their logistic system.
Raj is so big,
the live of things so difficult.
Oh,
I can.
I imagine.
I met to some Russian girls two years
ago.
I say,
do you use Ad Express?
A yes.
Oh,
sure.
Uh,
how long?
What about the speed of delivery?
They say it's great.
I said,
what do mean by grade?
She said,
only 45 days.
I mean,
Greg was 45 minutes,
not 45 days.
Now we've reduced from 45 days to 15
days,
but that is not enough.
Russia should have a more than logistics
system
that'd be able to deliver within 48
hours or 72 hours anywhere,
any place or Russia where you place on
an online,
we should get it within 72 hours and
this should have using technology.
This is your opportunity.
Young people logistics terrible and you
have the chess.
If were just as good,
we have no chunks.
We should have [inaudible] or the
payment online,
online payment today in China,
the mobile phone payment,
so popular.
I went to
see a few weeks ago,
I saw some beggars on the street.
You are you back money.
They use difficult mobile phone because
people don't have a pocket of money.
So we in a rusher,
we should have built up a good payment
system.
I'm more than payment system that every
young people can receive money,
pay money at the lowest cost.
Every young people should have be able
to reach financial assistance and we
should have good up Russia's art
express.
We should have built up a Russia,
alibaba.com this is what we want to do.
I'm okay whether on express someday in
Russia,
no business.
But we should have luck rushing young
people to develop its own logistic oh e
commerce platform all click the payment
platform.
We would love to join this force.
This is what we've been doing in the
past two years.
But how went to the Moscow university?
I have a,
I have a personal and dream in path two
years cause I'm not a good at a mess.
But computers size,
big cloud computing.
The basic is by the math.
Physics.
There's about computing technology.
Moscow university,
I think a,
you guys have the best of physics to
scientist and a mathematics.
So I would hope that Alibaba,
we just announced two weeks ago that we
invested 15 billion US dollars.
I'm building up a lab to solve the
problem for future solve the problem for
the world economy and social science.
So we hope that in Russia,
in Moscow we can viewed a lab that work
with the young excellent mathematicians
from Russia,
young physicist,
scientist from Russia.
We work together,
China rushing young people,
young scientists working together,
solve problem for future.
And I wanted to announce cure.
Our cto of chief technology officer is
coming to Moscow university very soon
and we want a high as many young people
as possible.
Join.
You don't have to work in China if you
don't like.
But if you love to work in China,
we are very happy you can work I office
here and joint together
full cloud computing,
big data for the future and artificial
intelligence and machine intelligence.
This is something we want to do.
You Russia and this is something we
wanted to do together with Moscow
university.
That was your talents.
Here we have technology,
we have data,
we have consumers,
we have a little bit money.
You have talents.
We work together.
We can do something really big in this
way.
We can make Alibaba the company of the
century.
I would like to hear your thoughts on
technology today.
Many people are wary of it and
especially about the impact of
artificial intelligence on jobs and
society.
What are your thoughts on this?
Um,
Jack?
Yeah.
Boy.
[inaudible] minogue.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] that
shot.
Don't worry about the future.
All right.
Don't worry about Tech College.
Let me tell you one thing.
Why are you worried about the future?
That is because you are a lack of
confidence.
You lack of imagination.
We don't have,
I may not have the solution for future,
but there is a solution for future.
We don't have the solution for future,
but our young people have a solution for
future.
I find and this wall,
young people don't worry about the
future.
Older,
the people worry for the future.
I've found those six.
Today's successful people,
they worry about the future.
Let me tell you,
future is the opportunity for everybody,
especially the opportunity for young
people because we have nothing to lose,
right?
This is what I tell myself.
18 years ago,
we did not have money so we can,
we have no money to lose.
We don't have the technology.
We have no technology loose
and then we say we believe 10 20 years
later,
e commerce.
Internet will be powerful if we start to
do now
when a lot of success people successful
people don't like technology,
don't like Internet.
We started doing 10 20 years later,
we will be the expert.
10 20 years later we'll be successful.
So I think don't worry about the future.
Prepare for the future.
Make your own future cloud computing,
big data,
artificial intelligence.
They are new to anybody.
You are successful,
new to you,
you are not successful,
new to you.
So what do you worry about?
Second thing is don't worry about the
things the other people worry about,
especially don't worry about the things
president and prime minister worry
about.
Worry about things you worry about.
We everybody have too many things to
worry about.
If you do not worry about yourself,
you worry too much about the world.
Now today,
Ali Baba should worry about the world.
You should not worry about the world
president of put these worry about what
you should not worry about the world.
You should worry about where you
graduate.
How can you make a living?
How can they do something that is
different?
How can you do something that is fun,
interesting,
and helping others?
By the way,
don't believe that technology is going
to take our way.
Human beings jobs.
Technology is going to replace a lot of
stupid jobs.
When the first,
the technology revolution come,
the steam machine comp people worry,
oh my God,
steamer,
she is going to take our,
we a lot of jobs.
After 50 years,
the steam machine created more jobs way
electricity comps.
Lot of companies worry about losing
jobs.
That electricity created so many jobs at
the Fisher intelligence,
they will create more jobs.
The problem is next to 2030 years may
lose credit,
lose a lot of job,
but this is shut period.
So we people have to learn how we can
survive in the artificial intelligent
period.
By the way,
why human being can wing machines,
machines,
they might be stronger deck human being.
They might be smart to that human being.
They might be rough faster,
the human being,
but they can never be as wise as human
beings because human being,
we have belief,
we have religion,
we have a heart,
which machine does not have.
So if you want to be ready for future,
please
did not follow yesterday's way of
learning and teaching.
Do not try to memory things harder and
more because computer can't remember.
Things are the more than you
do not try to calculate to faster
because the computer can,
cal could it much faster than you do.
So try to be creative,
tried to be innovative,
tried to be constructive.
These are the things,
everything you learn,
you think about is this thing can make
me more creative.
This one can be mum making me more
innovative.
This thing can be make me more
constructive as do it.
And also I think when other people
worry,
opportunity comps,
make them worry.
You should know nobody will and nobody
can stop this technology revolution.
You worry,
it comes.
You don't worry.
It comes.
So what's the point of a worry?
So I said people's a jet.
Have you ever cried in the past 18 years
doing the business internet in China?
I don't cry because I know quiet does
not make any sense.
Does that help me?
If cry can help me,
I would cry every day.
We should not have cried.
We shouldn't make competitors cry.
So think about,
be positive.
Get ready for that.
If you,
people from Moscow university cannot a
solve the problem.
If you worry the whole,
whoa,
19 nine 9% of people have no future.
So don't worry about it.
The positive started do it.
And when people worry,
open the door,
see what are the worry about and the
solve the problem.
That's what I think.
And we will work together.
You're a great believer,
young people as a c and you spend so
much time with students and with young
entrepreneurs.
What advice is maybe some more you can
give to all of us?
Dick,
we watch in village more than two d but
[inaudible] [inaudible] that,
yeah,
I love to be with young people first.
I'm still yom.
And a second is that when you mel young
people,
you know,
you're young all the time and young
people are the solutions for tomorrow.
Okay.
Young people are the solutions for all
the worries.
Uh,
young people.
If you stay with them,
you will be full of energetic.
But the advice I give to the young
people is that also the advice I'd give
to myself,
that nothing is easy.
Nothing is free.
If you want to be successful,
you have to pay the price.
I'll IBA by 18 years to today's size.
Yeah,
we are lucky.
Oh,
we work much harder than most of the
people will never sleep well and sound
in the evening.
I travel last year,
867 hours a year in the flood plane in
the plane.
I'm working hard.
My team working very hard.
18 years.
We work like a normal company.
70 years,
day and night.
Nothing is free.
Nothing is easy.
Easy beings.
You have to think different.
You have to do different.
Yeah.
If you,
everybody,
if a John said this is the right you for
John,
why you so you have to think,
for example,
early days in my company,
where's some ideas come to my desk.
Jack,
he's is a great idea and I look in every
like everybody's saying it is a good
idea.
Uh,
normally through into the rubbish
because everybody say there's good.
Then all the other people think of,
if everybody say this is going to be
very tough.
I'm very interested in that tough
question and a pickup and see how can we
do in a different way.
This is to be unique,
to be different and the third,
this is my advice and this is also
telling myself every day today is very
tough.
Tomorrow is more tougher.
The day off tomorrow is beautiful,
but most people die tomorrow evening.
You have to work very hard every tough
days,
every tough situation,
problems with meat.
That is the training of yourself
where you graduated at your school,
Ooh,
graduate from this school.
You just to start to your career of
learning,
you got a Ph d diploma,
a bachelor diploma.
This is just a certificate.
Your Paris pay the tuition for four
years.
Your real challenge is where you leave
the college.
The real life starts.
The real exam stats,
the real test of stats.
That's life.
One thing you got lucky,
as I said,
if students from Moscow university
cannot survive,
19 9.9% of people in the world cannot
survive.
Only you have this confidence,
you will be able to face the challenge
of future.
You
do jack for all these stories for all
the sponsors.
And now I will turn to the audience and
you will have an ability and time to ask
your own questions and I'll appreciate
if you formulate them on English.
But if you have some problems,
we have someone who can repeat and we
will help you.
So who wants to be first?
Okay,
can you,
can you tell us who are you your name
and Bailey
law school?
Yes.
Oh,
my question is actually a little just
retold rhetorical.
So the times from one market is more
complete and there are times when market
is more competitive as an error is it's
hard to keep being confident on yourself
and your future.
Okay.
So you formed the Lord Department.
The question is that in the time the
market is going to be more competitive,
how can you keep the confidence for the
future?
Right.
Knock it is never easy.
Okay.
In the early day,
just like a doing business is never
easy.
People say,
Oh,
I'm doing business more difficult.
No,
never is a continuum of more difficult.
The confidence is not.
The best way to do it is that find a
good team.
Find the people that share the same
vision,
same dreams,
work with them.
The only thing you listen is you listen
to grover up people.
If you doing a company,
listen to customers.
If they are happy,
if they your customers are happy,
don't worry too much.
You Stu,
have competitive.
Is your companies of your customers
happy?
Listen to your colleagues,
your team,
a big confidence.
If they have confidence,
don't worry about it.
Don't listen to a divisors lawyers.
I'm sorry.
Don't listen to those people are you
have no chance whether the market as a
child,
so not custom tell you,
your colleagues tell you.
So
nobody is the expert of future.
Most of the experts I yesterday.
So for the future,
the best way you learn it is know the
early days.
Ali Baba had no money,
no revenue,
nobody pay us
the revenue.
We got all the,
all the email of thanks from customers.
The customer send us email.
Oh Ali Baba,
you're so great.
You're helping me a lot,
but I don't have money to pay you fine.
We know one day they will pay if we
really help them.
So the confidence is from the customer's
confidence is from your team.
Hey,
y'all competitors always tried to
destroy your competence.
If your competitors spend a lot of time
is joy,
competence or confidence,
that means you're good.
Thank you.
Oh,
oh,
sorry.
No,
my question is going to be
watching price from us
as well.
To me just keep,
uh,
Jack,
my question is going to be a bit
sophisticated.
Well,
each is going to be regarding Russia and
delivery system.
Uh,
that's,
you inspired us to build up,
to build up the good one better than it
is now.
Uh,
however,
obviously we do not have this financial
opportunity that your company has steel.
We do not have a labor model delivery
now.
Well,
it as the first question,
second question.
Uh,
he does all of this that as like ass
others fees of production of goods and
services in Russian economy is
monopolized by government corporations.
What do you think of prospectus and
efficiency in Thomas in terms of
economic development of this current
situations
in the current market?
Thank you.
Good crushes.
The first question is will a good of a
logistic system,
but we don't have as much money as Ali
Baba,
so how can you be successful?
Right?
Tell me anybody who has some money for
building up our logistics system.
Okay.
I don't have money for good apple.
I don't think Ali Baba has the money to
build up rusher logistic system
cost then is then as billions of money.
Nobody has the money back has the money
they would not give you.
This is the opportunity.
You don't it first.
It's impossible to build up of
sophisticated at the logistics.
Them within one year takes about 10 1512
years and you have to do little by
little.
Okay,
this is the challenge.
I got nine year to file the one who's on
them to people's came to me say when we
go for raising money,
people ask,
how can you be successful?
No Internet in China enough,
no logistic,
no credit card,
no money,
no talents.
How can they be successful?
This question,
I'd been challenged year up to you
because everybody has no money.
That's the opportunity for entrepreneurs
sync.
Great.
If every business stopped from tiny
business,
we,
well we start Alibaba,
we try,
I go to a lot of,
I go to China Post.
Yeah.
I go to SOS say,
can you help us to deliver this are no,
no,
no.
You're too tiny to small.
We don't deliver.
So we went to the entrepreneurs who want
to deliver from their own village on
city owned properties.
So we're helping them
today.
We
65 million packages per day in China.
We delivered them.
How many people work here on that?
3 million people working on that.
We never do ourselves.
We do that a high 3 million.
We help them get the jobs.
So let me tell you,
15 years ago,
Chinar logistic system was so bad trying
to post same speed like the Russia
today,
nobody believe it to work.
How can you work,
right?
China is also a big country.
The only thing is we have a bet more
population,
more people,
but
we think it's opportunity.
The developer countries,
the logistic cost of the economy is
today 12% of the GDP of the other cost
country and I can China under developed
countries developing countries,
they like six 16%
today because of the Internet we are
able to lower down to seven and 6% this
depends on you.
It's your opportunity.
If you want to do it,
it's young.
If,
if young people want to do it,
you will be.
There's a chance.
Don't talk to success.
This woe to convincing successful people
is the most difficult thing.
We are not successful.
You say I want to deliver this thing for
my city.
I don't think about the whole rusher
just in my city.
You will win if you say I want to build
up a whole logistic for whole rusher.
You don't have channels.
Nobody would give you money because
everybody working for same cities where
you connect,
it's going to be big.
This is my advice.
Rusher has chest.
You can learn a lot from Alibaba
experience sharpton.
Hm.
Right.
So we are our,
our packages delivered every day off our
company alone.
Big then whole us and package hold
country.
We made it happen in 10 years.
You also can make it happen,
right?
It's not about money.
When you do,
right,
where do proper,
if you do the right direction,
money will come.
If you,
a lot of people say,
if I have money,
I'm going to do this.
I say,
you will never have the money.
If you do this things delicate,
you really want to do it a made
progress.
Money will come.
This is the first question.
Second is have a monopsony.
Yeah,
rusher.
I saw Moscow very beautiful this time.
Much cleaner,
more traffic,
very sad,
but I've never been to a lot of other
cities.
I think Russia economy should be focused
on more private business.
Small Business.
Not sure.
We really rely on the oil.
Gasoline amage big s he stayed on the
business.
Big private company.
We should have more entrepreneurs.
Dynamic,
tiny,
small business and this is what we
think.
This is the future
business model of 21st century.
I think if we have more small business,
every small business can export thing.
Well,
by the way,
let me tell you,
people say,
oh,
Russian commerce and very developed
Russia.
Ecommerce
today is a tiny infant baby less than a
baby.
Your ecommerce put together less than 1%
of the total Russia retail.
It's more like a 12 years ago.
China.
It's a huge opportunity,
but don't wait for the monopoly.
They would do it.
Don't wait for the SOE.
Don't wait for the logistic ready.
Don't wait for the back.
Ready.
You should do before they are ready.
If everything's already why they need to
you
is everybody.
Everything's already.
You have no chance because everything's
already you have the chance,
but get ready for the tough days.
Thank you.
Curly hair.
Oh,
of course.
Of course you will be next.
Uh,
and uh,
yeah.
Thank you.
Yeah.
First let me tell you that the language
is very important
that you speak good English does not
mean you will do global business
knowledge or don't use.
He made a speech here,
right?
Maza dog does not speak,
uh,
English.
Nixon did not speak Chinese,
but this older two guy made a global
deal.
China,
us,
you're working together.
It's the vision.
It's the belief that you have that
change the world.
But let me tell you another thing.
Language is so important.
It helped me a lot because of artificial
intelligence.
In the future,
you don't,
people say,
I don't need to learn English or Russian
or Japanese or something.
A chip here can check later quickly.
No,
it's not about language.
It's about the culture where you learn
the other language.
You start understand the other culture.
You start to appreciate,
respect the other culture where you
appreciate respect the other culture.
You will be respected and appreciated by
the others.
Then you can work it out together.
I learned my English by myself when I
was child.
I never got to one day English training
class all side China,
but I think I understand the western
culture much more better than those
Chinese students study outside because
I'm not learning language and learning
culture
where you respect the other culture
where you appreciate the other culture.
It's easy to make friends if you don't
like the other culture.
You will never make friends if you don't
have friends,
how can you do business?
So I would say language helped me a lot,
but most thing helped me is my respect
for the different culture.
I wish I could speak Russian.
The more I come here,
the more I learn a lot.
I asked one of the Russian guy,
why no rushing through tough and Chinese
too gentle.
How can they mix together?
And he asked you a very good,
he said,
check this country is so code.
We have to be tough.
I the house is so good weather so we
don't have to be tough.
Yeah.
So
if you,
if you have to everything with a
translator,
no.
Cool.
Sometimes you have to write,
but if you can't understand a language
that can community,
it's easier for you to communicate.
Easy to understand and be understood.
Thank you.
I hope I answer your question.
So
let's ask this girl who turned one to
Tusk and then someone next.
Yup.
Please.
Please present yourself.
Yup.
Hello,
my name is [inaudible] Tech
Entrepreneur,
uh,
and then founder of hydro,
which is a unique nona cosmetics,
a brand for apparel and footwear is it
was developed here in Moscow State
University.
Uh,
so my question,
um,
Mr Ma,
before you created an Alibaba,
all the small businesses in China,
all the small manufacturers is they
didn't have access to the global market.
And right now we have a similar problem
in Russia,
but wasn't intellectual products,
not was manufactured goods,
not with commodities,
but with innovations,
with inventions.
Like look at this audience is this pool
of scientists and inventors and we have
many more,
we'll have millions of talented people
in Russia who are developing a high
quality,
creative and innovative technologists.
But our local market is too small.
It cannot digest and it's a huge waste
is,
and this such a shame that all of this,
um,
technologists are not serving to the
humanities.
So my question is,
what would you advise us to do in order
to give to Russian intellectual
products?
Uh,
access to the global markets.
All right,
thank you.
Sure.
Lot of people have a great technology
inventions,
but they cannot do a,
Russia is too small market and the
offside market,
there's no access.
So what's,
how can do it pops in though with the
others
popped into was a company like Alibaba.
Okay home.
So a lot of people,
if you are good that invention,
but you may not a good at the marketing.
If you're good at marketing,
normally you're not a good animation.
So people need to work it together.
If you have a great invasion or you
extremely strong and good at invention
and creative to college,
must've fine good business people to pop
in there
and finding good.
So like me,
I know little about technology
today.
I'm so happy we don't use PC.
The only thing I can use my pc and the
sen receive email and the brows,
I don't know how to use to.
I'm happy we all use a mobile phone.
I'm not a technology guy,
but I know if we,
if I want to,
if we want to realize our dream,
we must have the technology.
But if I don't know the technology,
we should invite the best engineers and
science I worked with them or listened
to them.
Nobody can do anything.
What you should do is always
form a team.
I think
it is very difficult to make exact
company like Alibaba.
Again,
you can make a company better than
Alibaba,
but it would be difficult to make exact
business model.
Our model,
I will not say be great,
but it's a very workable our model
because of 18 years,
especially for the first 10 years,
nobody believe it.
Everybody say Jack,
my stupid crazy too is something that
will never make money.
So the smart people,
rich people never be our competitors
that give us chance.
So
finding good partner,
find a good team
and always focus on the things that you
are good at.
Focus on the things that you love
and that is the record of partnership.
I see that.
I give you a device for those young
people.
If you
uh,
20 to 30 years old,
please find a good boss.
Not,
not necessarily good company.
Learn from the bus.
Learn how to do it while you have 30 to
40 years old.
Try to do something yourself if you
really want to try while you're 40 to 50
years old,
two things that you are good at after 20
years of learning is you should do
something or good at where you are.
50 to 60 years or so.
Spending time supporting young people
where you are.
Sixth over 60 are sold.
Spend time with your grandchildren.
Right.
Is normally a lot of people like that.
So where you are graduate,
why you just in the university don't
think about I want resigned from the
school and be under the Bill Gates
because Bill Gates left Harvard.
There's only one bill gates in the
world.
When you graduate find a company
most important.
Find a good boss.
They can see you,
discipline you and tell you what is good
and right is more important in a good
company.
Right.
Of course.
I'm good comment.
I go Boston even better
and then continue your life.
It's all about the partner.
Sure.
Thank you.
These guys one?
Yes.
You or your friend.
Okay.
Well yeah,
I'm not supposed to meet him across from
yes.
And it will be the last question.
Sorry.
I'm fortunate to be our time runs out.
Okay.
Can you
repeat it?
Yup.
I'll just repeat the question.
So every week.
So um,
she said three weeks ago,
Alibaba launch team all in Russia and is
wondering what opportunities there are
for people in the room to contribute to
to Alibaba is team all team.
How will you and your team developed
team all here in Russia?
Okay.
Thank
you very much for this question.
I think Timo rusher is something that
Web testing
personally my wish is that she more
rusher k in spy.
As many people,
as many entrepreneurs as possible,
they can do the same thing.
We not necessarily want to make Timo
Russia big.
I hope you understand my seat cause we
don't want Ali Baba one day become the
largest e commerce company in Russia.
This is no,
this is my dream.
This is not our dream.
We won by work held Timo rusher.
Lot of no house,
lots of experience,
lots of things we'll learn from Russia
market.
Can you share with people so more young
people in Russia start to do things our
ecommerce,
that is something that really want to
do.
So we
sing that
Alibaba.
Aliexpress is something we want to do a
better job.
Odd Express today is helping Chinese
products.
Oh,
you're a or you ship product to Russia.
The peppers is what we want is help you
Russian products to the world.
This is what we want to do.
So we are very,
very happy that we are just her.
Before I came here,
I was,
I was having a lunch with our team in
Moscow.
We have about 100 colleagues here
and I sat
in 10 15 years,
we must have 5,000 people in Russia.
That means we need at least four foul
than 900 people.
These 5,000 people is not to the economy
because five people do ecommerce in
Russia does not a work.
5,000 people kiss support rusher,
sme to do ecommerce.
5,000 people can help logistic to
better.
5,000 people can help payment better.
5,000 people can helping the sme
promoting their products better.
So this is our thinking.
So many people keep on asking me,
Jack,
you know you are coming here to conquer
and the occupy a whole rusher.
You're not going to take our way.
A lot of our business,
no,
no.
This is not our purpose.
We're not Amazon Ali Baba.
No,
I mean we are better than Amazon.
We just have a different the business
model.
So we want to have him more talents from
Russia joining Ali Baba.
And we also have a lot of problems or
translation for Ali Express.
Right?
People say,
I have a funny translations,
which I'm sorry I don't understand,
but people say it's great we have a
unique language capability,
but I hope that
I ope
more and more young people in Russia
getting jobs because of ecommerce
infrastructure.
Finding jobs on the logistic but not
logistic does not mean delivered.
Logistic is smart logistic based on
data,
technology and payment.
So this is something about how to
joining Ali Baba.
I'm very happy to hear that.
And uh,
we have a office here and uh,
maybe I should,
uh,
right to my eating.
Yeah.
Okay.
Of course I ride a bike.
I'm not my email that my contact email,
the guys I don't read email.
Yeah.
I think the world is getting so
complicated by reading emails.
You write a long email with time.
She grier iml and then everybody remail
the efficient to the mobile phone is
much more efficient.
So,
but I leave email address of the,
uh,
of the contact.
So if you are interested at a,
working with Alibaba,
joining Alibaba and thinking about the
physics or computer or all math,
we'll be very happy and we will get the
email and contact you.
She's got money to you.
Y A N,
yeah,
at
Tom Bout right.